[Music]
let's go out to alex in louisville
kentucky and louisville what's up alex
hey guys how are you outstanding how are
you man
uh hanging in there good deal brother so
how can we help man
so um
basically my question is how do i get my
wife to start dreaming again um we're
about a hundred and ten thousand dollars
in debt
and uh that's the
i actually we've talked about it paying
all this off and really getting with it
and
getting this out of our life but
this the other day i finally sat down
and actually truly totaled everything up
not just that i think it's about this
and this and this
so that's when i came up with just over
a hundred ten thousand dollars and hey
stop right there
put me put me in your seat man was that
was that a scary moment
yeah i mean you know it was it was
bothersome to begin with but i mean
i didn't think it was that many digits
yeah uh
and uh you know it really made it
bothered me so much the other day i know
just i couldn't work and i mean i talked
about it non-stop i mean i've never
really had any problems with anxiety or
panic but i think that's the closest
thing to a panic attack that i've ever
had absolutely and um
i'm i'm ready to you know take on
another job there's fedex and ups over
here and i mean they're pretty flexible
and they actually pay pretty decent i
mean that'd be a whole nother 30 000 we
can add to the pile
a year but you know when i bring that
idea up it's
well i don't want you to get another job
because when i you know we get home you
know i really need your help with the
baby and
um you know if she could see herself
through my eyes she'd know that i mean
she's an awesome mom and i thought i was
an awesome dad and for being a
first-time dad and then
she comes home when i have him for the
day and he still wants to go to her so
she's that good well how old's your baby
nine months yeah brother don't take any
that personal man that
i i just i lost a lot of sleep and um
i had a lot of heartache over the first
with my first child um
wanting mom instead of me and i thought
it was because i i wasn't as good as her
and i was i was screwing something up
not the case man um that baby's
got a lot of stuff going on that does
nothing to do with you so um don't take
that stuff personal so have you sat down
with your wife
i can hear it in your voice
like yeah the word i would use to
describe what i'm hearing is scared
like this is the first time this thing
got real
does your have you sat down and told
your wife that you're scared you're
scared for your future you're scared for
y'all's small family any more kids are
going to come along does she know what
this is actually doing to the inside of
your guts and inside of your heart
i don't think she's
bad i mean i just think she knows it
bothers me but yeah i grew up in a you
know family where we just said just make
the payment man just make the payment
man just make the payment and uh
and i mean i really and to this day my
mom and dad god love them are still like
that sure
i don't want
any of that and i don't want any part of
it
i am oh you know admittedly i am the
spender but uh
you know she that's where she's kind of
the anchor to all this she's really
helped bring a lot of that in
if i could i feel like if i could just
get her to dream with me and see that it
bothers me
um i would you know we would actually
you know get somewhere but i don't know
how to even how do i have that
conversation
where it's productive and that it
actually you know i don't want to say
the wrong thing and you know come off as
you know being a jerk or yeah yeah
totally so i'm i'm gonna
i'm gonna give you part of it and then
george is gonna walk you through the
back half of the plan part i think
there's two two keys here
you you're right sitting down and
painting a picture together of what the
future could look like
if you guys got a hold of your finances
a hold of your communication
um a hold of being on the same page when
it comes to raising your kid what does
time look all that is extraordinary
the the the path into that is
vulnerability for you
it is sitting down and looking at your
life because right now she thinks this
is like you're annoyed like your
favorite football team is losing you
know what i mean she just has dumped
this over into things that husband rants
about
not
hey i'm having a panic attack my heart
is my body is starting to revolt on me
because i'm scared so you get a
babysitter which is gonna be hard for a
nine month old y'all get a babysitter
and you go out somewhere
and you sit down and say hey this is
gonna be a tough conversation i'm gonna
be honest as i can with you and probably
in a way you never have
and i'll tell you if you're speaking
from the heart and you're talking about
you not her you're not gonna say the
wrong thing if you make this into an
attack mode and you go after her then
that's just nonsensical and silly this
is about your heart right now and you
let her know honey i did all the math
and we're 110 grand in the hole
and i'm scared
and the only way out of this thing is
sacrifice we aren't safe we've put our
baby in a position um in a vulnerable
position we put our marriage in a really
precarious position
and the second part of this thing is a
plan and so george can walk you through
hey here's what here's what this
actually looks like because you've come
to your wife and complained about stuff
before you've ranted and raved about
stuff before and then she's rolled her
eyes and moved on because that's the
right response to someone just ranting
raven about nonsense the second part of
this is saying
and here's the plan yeah
so let's dig into some of the financial
part because i think part of this is you
do need a why like john's talking about
you need to have that conversation with
her
on a date night and go hey let's dream
about what our future could be because
right now it's obviously our present is
not great and so i think getting her to
dream about that aspirational future and
then coming up with a plan to get there
and sometimes that takes math where you
go hey look how much we're paying an
interest look how much of our money is
going to lenders every month and once
you do that she may get fired up and if
you guys haven't uh been through
financial peace university something
where you can get on the same page i'm
happy to gift you guys a year of ramsay
plus where you can dig in that
but what is your your household income
right now
uh
right about 120. 120.
okay great income there and you have
110k in debt what kind of debt is this
so it's a little bit of a mix of student
loans we have home repair loans about 30
that's for a mold remediation foundation
worth
combo
um and then that one hurts uh that one
hurts
oh yeah it really hurts
nothing like buying a house that you
love to find out it's got stuff grown in
it it's falling apart
that one hurts supposed to be taken care
of on the on the buy but it was not and
the contractor closed the business so
that really hurts
so uh there's that and there's a
personal loan there and then i think
about 15
or yeah 15 000 in a truck loan the other
card is paid off okay okay
well you've got a great income here and
uh if you guys can you're saying you're
willing to take on the side job to make
this happen right
oh yeah i've done it before i'll take
three
jobs i mean i don't care but i don't
want to do that because i want to do
whatever you do together
yes make sure you're on the same page
with it but if you let her know hey this
is a temporary sacrifice to get us out
of this mess uh and here's the
expectations i'm gonna be gone two
nights a week three nights a week
whatever that may be um
and we're gonna clean this up six months
faster if i do that i think that will
help you guys start to dream together
but i think if you can live on you know
a portion of your income you can get rid
of this debt in two years following our
plan most people can can do this in baby
step two do you have any money in
savings any cash right now
uh yeah we it's just a thousand dollars
so that was part of where we kind of
sort of i've
you know followed you guys for a little
while and so
without calling it the dave ramsey plan
yeah you know i've tried to start to
introduce it but it sounds like a dream
it just seems like you know that it
looks so full
well you hang on the line i'm gonna have
kelly pick up and gift you guys a year
of ramsay plus and what i want you to do
is get on the every dollar budget you'll
get every dollar plus through that and
you'll get access to financial peace
university just make a commitment sit
down start to watch some of those videos
dream together find that why develop a
plan and show her that you can get out
of this in under two years
i think they do in 18 months 100 he's
willing to work for it yeah if he's able
to get that second job and he's making
150 000 a year they owe a hundred and
100 grand 110 110 off 55. they could
look pretty spartan for a year they
could knock this thing out quick
um i get that question a lot
how do i help them
and the reality is
all we can control at the end of the day
is our thoughts and our actions the
things that we do the things that we
choose to think about and ruminate on
and spin out on
and so often instead of saying how do i
get them to get on board
it's
how do i invite them into what i'm
feeling and that's sitting down saying
i'm scared to
death and i got a plan